first tonight we want to turn our
attention to the work the president has
already been putting in just hours into
his first term brian
the president signing several executive
orders on his first day
but how much of an impact will those
decisions actually have on nevadans
8 news now reporter orc oh man is
speaking to experts and he has the
answer
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
president joe biden wasting no time on
inauguration day signing more than a
dozen executive orders
one of particular importance to the
silver state fortifies the daca
immigration program
which shields certain people who came to
the u.s as children
from deportation we have a lot of
friends and neighbors here in nevada who
are dreamers
according to the american immigration
council 12 000 dreamers lived in nevada
as of march 2020
the aclu of nevada tells me this
executive order also calls on congress
to create a path to citizenship for a
nevada dreamer
right now this means that there's some
sense of security at least right that
your situation will not change
immediately another executive order
extends the cdc's eviction moratorium
until at least march 31st but experts
say nevadans should focus on our state's
declaration form but in nevada because
the governor has enacted a stronger
eviction moratorium through march 31st
the cdc's eviction moratorium will have
no impact
one executive action that will impact
nevadans is extending the existing pause
on student loan payments through at
least september
our student body is majority of color
low income first generation all of these
risk factors and so they are the least
likely to have
funding for college while these are good
steps forward most agree
there is quite a bit of work left to do
orco mana 8 news now